Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, here is a voicemail about the
horrifying Salman Rushdie stabbing, which
we talked about on yesterday's bonus show.
This voicemail is from the Eggman,
who we have not heard from from for
at least a few weeks, if not a month or two.
Speaker 5: He did make a prediction that we will
never see Salman Rushdie in public ever again.
Either he is passed away or he's going to say
they're going to say he's dead, or he's
going to take his own death. That's it.
We'll never see him again. I hope he's okay.
But that's my prediction, Shallow brother.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I. So since the egg man left that
voicemail, the reports are that Salman Rushdie's
condition has improved, which is great. He is
now, I believe, if I understand, the last medical
report expected to survive, he's 75 years old. And
despite the fatwa officially being formally being
rescinded, we all knew he was still at risk.
Does a public appearance and he get stabbed?
It would be perfectly logical for Salman Rushdie
to never show his face in public again. And it's
sad that that's the reality of the situation.
But there is a contingent of people determined
determined to see Rushdie dead. And so, I mean,
making his own death or simply never appearing
in public again, honestly, the situation is
so crazy that it all seems somewhat rational.
If he were to do something like that for now,
let's just continue hoping for his recovery.
We have a great bonus show for you today. We
will talk about the complete and total backfire
of the Mehmet Oz Crudity video, which, by
the way, I covered months ago, months and
months ago. It's not a new video, but it's gone
viral. The Biden administration has canceled
almost $4 billion in student debt for more than
200,000 borrowers. We'll tell you who and why.
And the NBA. The National Basketball Association
has decided it will not hold games on Election Day
in order to encourage people to vote.
And of course, right wingers are furious,
even though the NBA is just saying just go
vote. We're not telling you who to vote for.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Get access by signing up at join Pacman dot.